I want to fall with him on Thursday you
know if I'm still here
and yeah madam I'm in a real good space
right now I'm at peace I'm last week I
came in here real positive I'm still I'm
still oh now I want to ball with them on
Thursday if I'm still here what a
strange thing to hear but that's where
we are right now in the National
Football League
Chris Jalen Ramsey wants out of
Jacksonville making no bones about it
and we'll see if he gets what he wants
but with each guy who gets what he wants
it underscores that today's NFL players
have power that maybe they didn't have
in the past where the team would insist
on everyone being treated the same way I
think we need to acknowledge that when
you have a star player maybe he does
merit different treatment to ensure that
he wants to be there whether it's how
much he makes whether it's whether the
rules that apply to everyone else apply
to him whatever the case may be right
it's incumbent on the team to manage the
relationship in a way that the star
player wants to stay because if he
doesn't there's gonna be somebody else
who is willing to give up a first-round
pick two first-round picks whatever it
takes to get him ya know I mean we're
seeing that a lot really - I mean you
know with teams not making their stars
happy I mean we could talk about the
Giants and Odell Beckham jr. that way -
but you're right it's a new age in the
NFL and really Mike you know these star
players at least you know they've always
had this power I think they've just kind
of realized how to take advantage of
and use it to their benefit and I think
finally some of these star players have
realized with social media and
everything you know guys are gonna fan
some people the media they're gonna hate
me no matter what sometimes so why not
just force way the force things the way
I want them and go to a place where I'm
gonna be happy at and and then just deal
with the criticism that way but I mean
the guys Antonio Brown certainly started
a new trend like a whole new power play
but you know to me it starts von miller
aaron donald the way they handled their
franchise negotiations and all that hey
Kaleo Mack the Raiders didn't want to
pay him right right they get the guy in
the top five of the draft the idea is
try to find Hall of Fame players with
those draft picks when you get him you
cling to him
the Raiders mishandle the negotiations
and got themselves back to in a corner
and the day after Aaron Donald got a
record-setting contract for defensive
players that's when the Bears swooped in
paid Khalil Mack even more and happily
gave up two first-round draft picks
which tells you the value of a
transcendent Talent and the teams that
get these guys have to figure out how to
make it work you got to pay him you got
to make them happy and if you fail in
those two respects they're going to want
to play for someone else and there will
be someone else out there who says bring
him on yeah we'll give you first-round
picks
cuz we use those first-round picks
precisely to get guys like this ya know
there's no doubt there's gonna be a
market for those type of players they're
just too special I mean you know I mean
even with Antonio Brown I know the
Patriots didn't know everything you know
they had some curveballs but there they
were I mean Antonio Browns been a mess
for a while here but the talent on the
field and they feel like okay well it's
worth the risk and we got the culture
that can then take a guy like Antonio
Brown in but the market is it is real
for those superstar players and you know
I think one of the things that I always
hear and na even had some people text me
yesterday like as far as like why or why
do why do fans in the NFL get so mad at
the players when the players have this
type of power and then you look at
things like the NBA and sports like that
where it's not is
the fans aren't as critical on players
as they are about you know Jalen Ramsey
requesting a trade or you know anybody
else out there what is your thought to
that why I think with NBA players I
think the fans have just accepted the
fact that if you are a fan of the Bulls
and the Cavaliers of the heat whoever
you're just kind of temporarily renting
the guy anyway and I also think NBA fans
plenty of them follow the player right
so I'm I'm not a Cavs fan I'm a LeBron
James fan
so we're bran James is that's my team so
I think that's why the guys get less
criticism it's more individualized with
the NFL level the fans are zealous about
their team and how dare you disrupt this
good feeling I have about my team by
wanting out I think that's the
fundamental difference yeah I'm with you
there right I mean you're you're loyal
to that you know purple helmet and that
whatever the hell that thing is on the
side of their helmet your loyalties that
went through yes I mean you'll talk some
crap about their players aka Kirk
Cousins but you're still loyal to that
brand and that team I used to be I hate
everybody equally yeah sure you do okay
whatever you say slugger
but but but I do like this look it's
gonna make for things crazy it's gonna
make our job more fun but it is a
business and the players have become
businessmen more than ever the last two
years in the NFL to really realize the
you know the the avenues they have that
take advantage of the system and give
themselves some power here yeah and I
agree with you and look I I go to
Antonio Brown and and I still it it
appears that the player wanted out and
got out right yeah both of Pittsburgh
and of Oakland but but I I feel like
especially in Pittsburgh they wanted him
out but they didn't feel compelled to
make it known that they wanted him out
right they were happy to get rid of him
they were happy to unload him they were
at the point where they had enough and
the Steelers I believe were willing to
do whatever it had to do they had to do
to make Antonio Brown happy look at how
many times they tweaked his contrast
right good all the things we found out
about
being chronically late and having his
own place at training camp off-campus
and not staying in the dorm with his
teammates they had different rules for
him they did coddle him until they got
to the point where they decided they had
enough and I really do think that it was
more mutual than then it was it was a
characterized as but the problem is it
feeds this narrative that players if
they want out can get out yes no it does
and you know yeah with an Antonio Brown
yeah they've been doing all the things
you're you're right that you've been
saying you got to make the star player
happy you got to appease to him they
were but Antonio Brown just kept taking
and taking and taking and kept moving
that line to where yes Pittsburgh
finally was like the hell of hell with
it
but yeah between Antonio Brown and then
Ezekiel Elliott really drawing a line in
the sand two years before he's supposed
to become a free agent I mean I think
those are two players we look at right
now that have changed the game in the
landscape ultimately for the NFL and
here's the caveat at some point the
players talent no longer justifies it
and that's when he is gone I will be
right back
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports